pour le trophée de l'image de l'année
[Musique]
afida turner
[Applaudissements]
jean marie le pen
vous
[Musique]
l'homme arbre
voici les images de la conférence de
presse qui s'est tenue quelques jours
plus tard notre radicalité est
nécessaire pour changer un monde qui
s'autodétruit avec obstination
moundounga samares
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poule à
et isabelle
non
[Musique]
le best seller membres mais ça manque
d'émotion c'est pour cela que j'ai fait
le yoyo ou à l'africaine pour réveiller
un peu les tuniques écornée alors les
cherry hill et beaucoup de matches de
l'année
sachez que jean marie le pen est là ce
soir
[Rires]
l'image de l'année c'est lui il gagne
mamoudou gassama ils attendaient tous ce
soir à manhasset
[Applaudissements]
c'est grave encore le sud est
mort à l'hôpital
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi c'est moi que l'elysée mais
c'est un trophée taurin voilà qu'il faut
avoir mamoudou je suis très fier et très
content que tu sois avec nous ce soir et
je voudrais te dire bravo voilà pour ce
que tu as fait une fois de plus tard il
est bon nous tu seras l'image
merci beaucoup c'est vraiment un amour
de nec
je veux dire merci d'être là et heureux
est ce que tu es heureux vente mamoudou
je te sens heureux dans la cei et est
moins fatigué que la donne a fois tu
étais heureux ce sont bien la regarder
des valeurs du cac c'est le héros de la
boutique ne change rien il ya toujours
rire était exceptionnelle en termes
forts en tout cas merci mahmoud août
je remercie tout le monde si beaucoup
merci mamoudou merci d'avoir été là
merci ça va
il aura choisi